stop à l'asphyxient des départements
c'était le message hier des 400 élus
réunis devant l'assemblée nationale face
aux baisses drastiques des dotations de
l'état une baisse qui concerne aussi le
département des yvelines à hauteur de
288 millions d'euros ce sont des sommes
absolument considérable que l'état ne
nous donne plus
alors que il décide de nos dépenses les
dépenses sociales et ils ne compensent
pas alors que normalement il a cette
obligation constitutionnelle pour le
seul département des yvelines sur un
budget d'un milliard d'euros c'est plus
de 280 millions d'euros que les
partenaires nous toi chaque année donc
vous imaginez bien que nous sommes
obligés de baisser le service ovi noir
et d'augmenter la fiscalité ce qui est
doublement d'insupportable est assez
dure pour les yvelinois ces couples ont
des conséquences sur les dépenses
sociales comme le rsa l'apa pour les
personnes âgées ou encore l'éducation
c'est un budget important fonctionnement
125 millions d'euros par an
on ne peut pas le diminuer il faut bien
que les élèves et
il faut à la rentrée on compte qu'on
continue à entretenir nos collèges qu'on
puisse
aussi équipé en informatique voilà donc
fouillé tout vu et tout un plan à la
fois en investissement fonctionnement
donc cette baisse nous nous nous a fait
prendre des décisions qui sont des
lourdes répercussions sur les yvelinois
et c'est pour dire ça suffit
aucun représentant du gouvernement n'a
souhaité réagir sur cette mobilisation
mais les élus ne perdent pas espoir ils
tenteront à nouveau de se faire entendre
lors du congrès des départements à
poitiers du 5 au 7 octobre